I want to share with you my 12 step
YouTube video production checklist so
that you can ultimately create your best
videos before the shoot day it's nice to
lay everything out and make sure that
you have all of the necessary gear if
you fail to plan you plan to fail the
best content creators on YouTube
research before they press record I've
made a lot of mistakes over the years
and had a lot of frustrating moments in
my career as a content creator but this
is one of the things I wish I knew when
I was starting
I love checklists I've learned that it's
better to have a short pencil than a
long memory I don't know about you but
when I'm filming my YouTube videos
there's been so many times when I've
forgotten to mention something in the
video when I forgot to set something up
right when I showed up to a shoot and I
forgot to charge the batteries so in
this episode of the think media podcast
I want to share with you my 12 step
YouTube video production checklist so
that you can have less stress s on your
next shoot and make sure you don't
forget anything and ultimately create
your best videos today's episode is
brought to you by tube starterkit.com we
have a cool sale happening right now on
one of our coolest bundles of digital
assets for helping you with your YouTube
channel so you can check that out in the
show notes and I will tell you a little
bit more about that later but let's get
into the 12-step checklist number one
schedule time on your calendar for when
you're going to shoot your video I've
learned this what gets scheduled gets
done and so one of the most powerful
things you can do in preparation for a
shoot is actually planet now this is
actually part four of our YouTube
productivity series and in part one we
talked about batch shooting and so this
checklist will certainly help you shoot
one video but I love to use this for
shooting multiple videos at one time you
can check out the show notes for a link
to the past episodes where we talk more
about that but when I'm using this
checklist my goal is to actually go into
a shoot day where I'm going to shoot one
two three four video videos all at once
and so it's really important to number
one schedule that and plan for that and
make sure it's on your calendar number
two research your videos ahead of time
we've all heard the saying if you fail
to plan you plan to fail the best
content creators on YouTube research
before they press record now this is
different than actually outlining your
video this is time spent analyzing
competitors doing keyword research topic
research actually coming up with the
best video ideas possible so that you're
using your video shoot day effectively
with the best kind of content that's
going to get the most views once you
have identified some strong video ideas
and strong video topics step number
three is to outline the content of your
videos now when I say outline I don't
necessarily mean script however it is
definitely okay to script out your
videos and perhaps use a teleprompter
personally an outline for me is exactly
what I'm you using right now and it's a
list of the 12 points and details and
bullets of what I actually want to say
and then using my outline I kind of
extemporaneously communicate around the
information The Helpful thing though is
I'm actually batch producing videos
right now on a shoot day pretty meta
because I'm actually using these very
principles and tips that I'm sharing
with you today and so the way I can stay
structured to make sure that the
information is actually delivered
clearly and that it's as helpful as
possible to you is because I'm working
off an outline I use Google Docs which
is free to use where I've outlined these
videos and I also highly recommend
following the perfect video recipe we
won't go into that today but I will link
to a free podcast series on the perfect
video recipe in the show notes number
four prepare your gear before the shoot
day make sure you charge your camera
batteries lay out any gear you're going
to use so there are no surprises when
it's time to record have you ever lost
something around your house maybe you
lost your keys maybe you lost your
wallet and it's super stressful
especially when you're late trying to
get somewhere well this is even more of
an issue when it comes to creating video
content over the years as I was shooting
videos especially as a solo Creator I
would often times wonder where actually
is the battery where is that power cable
where is that lens or that lens cap
where is that microphone where is the
cable for the microphone and as you
collect gear and build out your YouTube
Studio there can be a lot of little
pieces or little details that are
critical to your shoot this is also true
if you ever travel and you try to pack
your gear into a suitcase or a backpack
there's nothing more frustrating than
getting to a shoot and you're missing a
critical piece to the setup this is why
before the shoot day it's nice to lay
everything out and make sure that you
have all of the necessary gear for when
it's time to record number five so
select a location if your life is
chaotic like mine then you know that it
could be hard to find a time and place
where there's not screaming kids in the
background noise yard work isn't it true
that whenever you're about to film a
video the neighbor starts to mow his
lawn or use his high-powered gas leaf
blower which is crazy noise when it's
time to shoot seems to be Murphy's Law
and so you want to ultimately think
ahead about how to create an environment
with minimal background noise that's
ideal for shooting videos one of the big
questions people ask me is Sean there's
no clean areas in my house there's no
real areas without clutter and one of
the things you could do is prepare
almost like a photo backdrop these can
be very affordable off of Amazon and you
can get a paper backdrop or you can get
a cloth photo backdrop interestingly
enough if you're watching the video
version of the think media podcast
behind me is a fake wall it's actually a
paper wall wherein the loft of Kyle
Anderson's and Anderson Studios and so
you could do a lot by using maybe some
simple things that are purchasable on a
website like Amazon or a local
photography store but the point is think
ahead about making sure the location is
right get your gear right think about
the location and maybe think about the
time of day when you could send the kids
to the babysitter or have Mom take them
or maybe your house is chaotic and noisy
Could you actually shoot somewhere else
could you swap houses and shoot in the
unused basement that Mom and Dad aren't
using or a friend or whatever number
five select a location now number six is
prepare your wardrobe and any other
visuals or props I like to shoot
multiple videos at one time and then
release them over successive weeks and
so I will prepare shirt and outfit
changes and hat changes just because
that's part of my personality but a
disclaimer here that some people wonder
is you know do I have to change my shirt
and the answer is no the truth is people
don't really know on YouTube if you're
wearing the same shirt in every video
some creators wear the same black
t-shirt in every video but I know that
other creators like Dr Andrea Ferlin she
mentioned she gets her hair done before
her batch shoot days and even go
shopping to buy some outfits it's part
of her personality it's something that
she wants to do the key is whatever your
vision is for the brand and look and
visual variety of your videos
preparation goes a long way I grabbed a
couple different outfits for today's
shoot and I actually pulled out a
steamer so that I could get the wrinkles
out so that I wasn't rushed going into
today's batch but the other piece is
even more important and that is make
sure to grab any visuals and props that
you may want to use in your video some
of our community likes to teach content
from a whiteboard and they want to use
maybe a paper white board or a
traditional whiteboard and you got you
want to make sure sure that your pens
aren't out of ink right if you've been
using that Sharpie or you probably
shouldn't use a Sharpie on a white board
but you're using the dry erase marker
and like it's out of dry erase ink if
that's what it's called or it's not the
tip isn't very thick and so you're
trying to it's like not even showing up
on camera thinking ahead about what are
people gonna see what do you want to
prepare what do you want to get ready
for example if you're going to be doing
a book review it's great to maybe get
the book in hand and I know for me if
I'm rushed and I'm looking for one book
in my house I'm probably not going to
find it like I need to do that ahead of
time make sure that I set it out set it
to the side or if you have any other
props in your videos which is kind of a
separate tip one of the ways to charge
up the visual experience of your video
is think about what props could you have
is there any visuals that would enhance
the content which brings us to number
seven get a good night's sleep and be
purposeful with your morning routine now
if you're just going to create one video
this might not be as important but but
if you have the audacity to try to shoot
four five six seven eight videos all in
one batch then being as well rested as
energized having as much mental Clarity
all of the above is very important and
so as you look ahead be thoughtful about
what you're doing the night before your
shoot day now all of this preparation
has led up to the actual shoot your
camera is set up you're ready to go your
microphone's plugged in and so number
eight is record and do a test video clip
so that you can review the audio and the
look of the shot I made a lot of
mistakes over the years and had a lot of
frustrating moments in my career as a
content creator but this is one of the
things I wish I knew when I was starting
there's actually been times when I have
shot multiple videos I hit record on my
camera I knew I had three videos to
shoot I shot all three videos all in one
sitting and I realized that my
microphone battery was dead or my
microphone wasn't on all I had was video
with no audio and footage was completely
unusable there's been other times when I
quickly review the video on the small
LCD screen on my camera or my phone only
to later look on it on a full-size
Monitor and realize my collar is flipped
up and realize there's like a stain on
my shirt because I wasn't really able to
analyze the look of the footage I've
left dirty towels on the background I've
had crooked pictures on the wall because
again I didn't just take the time to
analyze the video and the audio also
audio could have background noise there
could be a hiss there could be different
things that could be fixable there's a
joke among editors that says fix it in
post your goal is to not fix it in post
your goal is to perhaps adjust the
lighting maybe Shadows are weird maybe
there's some weird reflection on a glass
painting behind you a glass artwork and
you just move the light around maybe the
way the lights reflecting in your actual
physical glasses on your face these
things are fixable we have a channel
called think media with many tips in
this area but the key and this this tip
will save you a lot of pain and a lot of
time is sit down start your shoot
do just an opening clip 10 20 30 seconds
talk at your normal voice deliver just a
few moments of content and then take out
that SD card or if possible plug your
phone into your bigger laptop and try to
review the footage ideally on a larger
computer screen in a quiet environment
or with some headphones so you can hear
how does it sound how does it look is
your collar flipped up is the white
balance really weird is there a
distracting object in the background
because it's really nice to especially
get things right before you shoot
multiple videos in a row number nine is
shoot your video all the preparation has
led up to this point so it's time to hit
record and Own It number 10 shoot any
b-roll that you need for your video and
so what is the difference between a-roll
and b-roll well if you're doing a
talking head video delivering
information working off of your outline
or your script you on camera and you
your audio delivering that information
that is the a-roll and the reason that
you may call it that is in a video
editing timeline that's like the first
layer of content well we've all seen
from watching film or watching YouTube
videos that while somebody is delivering
some information it may even just be a
voiceover there's all these other clips
and there's all these other things
showing up on screen that is kind of
showing what they're talking about if I
was reviewing a product right now maybe
talking about a camera I could just sit
here holding the camera with the one
shot or I could also add extra clips
zoomed in showing different angles even
using different lenses and so all of
that extra footage is b-roll so it's
nice to have this as part of your
checklist because once your video is
over ask yourself is there any b-roll
that I want to shoot any extra footage
any extra clips any transition scenes is
there anything I could shoot that would
support the main content remember if you
begin editing and find out that you need
some footage it's very frustrating so
you want to ask yourself why you're
shooting is there any other maybe intros
or outros or things I missed or
supplemental footage that I just want to
make sure I have captured here's the
cool thing you don't actually have to
use it but I'll tell you this if you're
sitting in your boxers in the middle of
night when there's no daylight anymore
and it's hours after your shoot and
you're doing the edit and then you go
shoot I forgot this scene you're gonna
be really frustrated because it may be
almost impossible to recreate what you
need in that moment and so I always love
having extra footage if necessary or
just taking some time to have the b-roll
that can be helpful in the edit as you
know the thumbnail is one of the most
important parts of a YouTube video but a
lot of us find ourselves getting to the
edit and then thinking oh shoot I needed
to get a thumbnail and so we scrubbed
through our video editor timeline
looking for a moment where our face is
not contorted or distorted that would
actually be exportable and then be able
to be turned into a thumbnail and
ultimately that's one way of doing it
but again having a checklist because
it's better to have a short pencil than
a long memory that just reminds you okay
let me set a timer on my phone or a
timer on my camera and take a few still
shots that I could use for my thumbnail
even better maybe you want to step into
a different room a different environment
we used to shoot a lot of thumbnails in
front of my garage door because it was
the most minimalist kind of door in my
house and I had the daylight of being
outside typically in the shade I want to
say that there was probably two three
years of 99 of think media's thumbnails
was in front of my garage door and the
key was I would if I was talking about a
camera that was the item in the video
that was the visual or oftentimes
thumbnails don't have me in them and so
is the thumbnail about just a piece of
tech or some kind of product do you need
to do some product photography that
could be used in your thumbnail number
12. review and transfer your or video
footage now this is one of those steps
that if you miss it it can actually
cause a lot of stress and frustration so
the goal here is to set yourself up for
Success when it comes to video editing
and so this looks like putting the SD
cards in a safe and well organized Place
oftentimes I've maybe filmed sometimes
on a couple cameras or just one camera
and I took the SD card out of the camera
where is it where did it go maybe you're
not sure which SD card you're using are
you going to format it meaning are you
going to delete the footage on there
we'll have you captured it yet and if
you don't do it why it's fresh
oftentimes if time passes you could be
frustrated finding that original footage
so the basic step of this I like to put
a sticky note on my desk right on the
sticky note which videos were shot what
is on that SD card and then I set that
SD card on top of the sticky note the
problem with that strategy is if you
have a two-year and eight month old boy
wandering around your house destroying
your property and sabotaging your
belongings even that very plan could be
flawed as that SD card disappears
forever so even better is to actually
capture the footage and so in this case
you're done with your shoot you're
exhausted you want to just forget about
shooting and relax and then come to
editing later go the extra mile and
actually sit down at your computer or
your laptop and transfer the footage
from your SD card to your computer if
you're shooting on your phone transfer
the footage from your phone to your
laptop or to your computer unless of
course you're going to be editing on
that very same phone now a big key here
is to label and organize the content
intelligently so that you can ultimately
find it later if you add a multi-camera
shoot you may have camera a camera B
that's two different folders you may
have the photo files the image files
that are put into a thumbnail folder so
I'm speaking from my solo Creator days
when I would be batch producing videos
doing everything thing all by myself
after I would shoot the videos I would
sit down on my computer I would open up
a file folder I had it backed up on drop
Dropbox paying for a Dropbox business
account and I would have the a-roll
they're all the main footage I'd have
the thumbnails in a separate folder and
at that moment I might actually take a
break I may come back to it later I may
not edit at that exact moment but I was
always thankful that I reviewed and
transferred the footage when it was all
fresh and actually kind of a bonus tip
around number 12 comes from Tony Ariola
he's actually a former think media team
member he's now working for the XFL and
making different documentary films and
his tip is actually sitting down and
doing the first raw edit of your footage
right after you shoot maybe you're not
going to add all the b-roll in you're
not going to add in any extra fancy
transitions or anything but he likes to
get the footage actually on the timeline
edit the a-roll meaning the main portion
of content all the way through to see if
there's continuity there to see if you
hit the good you had made the points in
the middle good you actually just have
the raw materials because if it reveals
something like man I wish I would have
said that or I should transition this
here or I should add this part here you
still have the opportunity to do that
because you're still in the shoot mode
you got your camera set up you got the
Wardrobe you got it all going and
therefore you can add any supplemental
footage if necessary take a deep breath
I know that these 12 steps in and of
themselves may have sounded like a lot
but as you begin to master this skill of
content creation and use this checklist
you're going to have less stress on your
brain for making sure you hit all the
points so that you can have more energy
and more excellence and actually
shooting and creating your content so
you can add massive value to the viewers
and community that you are impacting now
today's episode is brought to you by
tube starter kit.com if you found this
checklist super valuable and you want to
print it out so that you can reference
it and check out a lot of other cool
things in this digital asset bundle just
go to tubestarterkit.com it's on sale
right now for a crazy good price and
you're gonna love what is inside of the
YouTube starter kit it actually has our
51 money making video ideas guide our 51
video ideas to jump start your channel
our 15 best YouTube title formulas for
getting views our YouTube Clarity
blueprint which is a multi-page PDF
download that'll walk you through
getting clear on your YouTube strategy
on your target audience we have
thumbnail templates that you can plug
into canva our video description
template and our create awesome videos
checklist there's so much cool stuff in
there and we actually just updated it
the value of all these resources
separately is over six hundred dollars
but we have it on sale right now for
think media podcast listeners so if you
want to just get more videos done in
less time you want access to some cool
downloadables and tools that'll just
help you go fast stir and reduce the
stress of creating content you're going
to love the starter kit so
tubestarterkit.com is where you can
check that out or just look at the show
notes of the podcast now if you found
this content valuable it would mean the
world to me if you rate like and review
the podcast wherever you watch or listen
and remember this is actually part four
of our YouTube productivity series and
so if you're just checking this episode
out and you want to check out part one
two and three where we talk about batch
producing content how to take one piece
of content and turn it into multiple
viral videos our best AI tools a lot of
helpful content that's going to help you
go faster help your YouTube production
workflow check out the playlist on
YouTube we'll link that uh in the show
notes or you can go back in the library
on the audio podcast I think you're
going to love the other episodes in this
series that you may have missed and I
can't wait to see you in the next one